everyone is concerned about how much you
make
no one is concerned about how much you
save and what's really important is the
amount of money you save which is called
the wealth what is your net worth
and so if you're squirreling away paying
off your debts getting equity in your
home
over time i almost guarantee you because
i i've seen plenty of
tax returns where the guy makes a
hundred seventy hundred eighty thousand
but he spent
a hundred ninety two hundred thousand
show for it and he got nothing to show
for it right
and so the guy who you know the the
tortoise and the hare classic story the
tortoise who swirls away 10
of his income and throws it into an
average returning mutual fund also
at the age of 35 40 he's sitting on a
quarter million dollars in liquid assets
and no debt
meanwhile the guy who's flash flashing
the cash and the boats and
and boats in the hose he doesn't have
anything to show for it but
as it pertains to women i've said this
before
women most of them do not know the
difference between debt or equity
spending
most women are woefully ignorant of
their finances let alone their man's
finances so when
this was very common in banking where
the guy
shipped didn't come in his house of
cards folded
the woman didn't realize that they were
never millionaires
and also in the house is repossessed and
they're evicted
and then of course she files for divorce
and she's shocked at all that
um so it really is kind of a game like
yeah like if you go with hanging out
with myron
there's a lot of peacocking going on
there there's a lot of guys
flashing the cash they don't have um
whereas
and it's true the women are going to go
for that because they see ooh shiny
objects shiny colors nice that's the
demographics of the sexual marketplace
for the most part there too yeah yeah it
is well and even myron he just creates
some
great insights that myron has where he's
like uh you know if it's a good-looking
gal she's sponsored like it's almost a
guarantee she has a guy who's who's a
sugar daddy
so the customer the competition is
fierce but you're not competing for
women
you're competing to have an early
retirement and an easy life
uh and that's why i think you gotta
separate the goals is
you are in this to be liberated from an
employer as
quickly and as soon as possible
you